SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM, THANK
YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
JOINING ME NOW, REPRESENTING THE
GREAT STATE OF OHIO, REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN.
I WANT TO CONTINUE WITH THIS
CONVERSATION ON NANCY PELOSI.
LOOK, SHE IS OVER THERE EATING
HER HIGH-PRICED ICE CREAM.
SHE IS COMPLAINING ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT.
LET’S TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT
IT APPEARS THE DEMOCRATS ARE
USING HIS WUHAN VIRUS, THEY WANT
TO CALL IT COVID, WHATEVER THAT
MEANS, AS A SUBTERFUGE TO PURSUE
THEIR PROGRESSIVE LEFTIST AGENDA
AS OPPOSED TO PROVIDING MONEY,
NEEDED DOLLARS TO AMERICANS.
WHAT SAY YOU?
REPORTER: THE DEMOCRATS NEVER
MISS AN OPPORTUNITY TO GO AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THEY ARE
SAYING WE ARE GOING TO PAY
STATES TO LET CRIMINALS OUT OF
JAIL.
THEY ARE SAYING ABORTION CLINGS
ARE ESSENTIAL BUSINESSES AND
THEY WANT TO STOP YOU FROM
BUYING A GUN AND STOP YOU FROM
GOING TO CHURCH.
AS THE SENATOR SAID WE SHOULD BE
COMING TOGETHER TO DEAL WITH
THIS VIRUS.
REPUBLICANS, WE WANT TO GO BACK
TO WORK.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THE SMALL
BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION LOAN
PROGRAM HAS THE FUNDS IT NEEDS.
NANCY PELOSI WANTS TO STAY IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND CRITICIZE THE
PRESIDENT.
JUDGE JEANINE: THE ORIGINAL
CARES ACT -- THE PAYMENT
PROTECTION PLAN IS OUT OF MONEY.
AND THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO NEED
THAT MONEY TO SURVIVE.
IN THE MEANTIME, SHE HAS TAKEN
MONEY OUT OF THAT $2.2VILLE
STIMULUS BILL TO DANCE AROUND
WITH THE KENNEDY CENTER AS IF
THE PHILANTHROPISTS CAN’T GIVE
IT MONEY.
HOW DID YOU LET THAT GET OUT OF
THE HOUSE?
>> YOU ARE RIGHT.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THE
PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM HAS
THE MONEY IT NEEDS.
BUT WE HAVE ALL THESE TASK FORCE
MEETINGS.
BUT THE ONE TASK FORCE THAT IS
SUPPOSED TO MEET TO ADDRESS BIG
ISSUES THAT FACE OUR NATION IS
THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS.
AND WE ARE NOT IN SESSION.
AND THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
SAYS WE ARE NOT COMING BACK INTO
SESSION UNTIL MAY 4.
HEALTHCARE WORKERS, TRUCKERS,
GROCERS, ALL KINDS OF PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN WORKING.
WHERE IS THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS?
ONE THING WE SHOULD DO,
PARTICULARLY ON THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT WHAT YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT IN OUR
OPENING MONOLOGUE WHERE
GOVERNORS ARE SAYING YOU ARE
GOING TO GET A TICKET IF YOU GO
TO CHURCH.
THE MAYOR OF LOS ANGELES SAID
SNITCHES WILL BE SPREE WARDED.
WHAT KIND OF MESSAGE IS THAT?
WE HAD A PROSECUTOR IN ONE OF
OUR BIG COUNTIES IN OHIO.
HE SAID IF HE WERE THE GOVERNOR
HE WOULD CALL OUT THE NATIONAL
GUARD TO STOP YOU FROM GOING TO
CHURCH.
EARLIER THIS WEEK ATTORNEY
GENERAL PUT OUT A MEMO TALKING
ABOUT RELIGIOUS LIBERTIES SAYING
YOU CAN’T DO SOME OF THE THINGS
BEING DONE BY THESE GOVERNORS.
JUDGE JEANINE: THEY CAN’T.
AS A PROSECUTOR, EVERY TIME YOU
GET A CONVICTION, YOU PHOTOGRAPH
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT
SOMEONE IS GUILTY.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT TAKES TO GET
SOMEONE TO GET A JUDGE TO SEND
SOMEONE TO JAIL.
NOW THEY ARE TELLING EVERYBODY,
GET THE CRIMINALS OUT OF JAIL.
THEY ARE TELLING ME I CAN’T
LEAVE, I CAN’T PLAY BALL WITH A
CHILD.
I CAN’T GO TO CHURCH AND YOU ARE
LETTING CRIMINALS OUT OF JAIL.
I HOPE AMERICANS ARE HEARING
THIS.
EVEN WORSE, THEY RAN OUT OF
MONEY.